I'm sue Desmond Hellman I'm Chancellor
at University of California San
Francisco and I want to tell you about
the drug development story for Herceptin
let me start by telling you about my
background I'm a medical oncologist by
training after medical school I came to
University of California San Francisco
and did my training in internal medicine
and then medical oncology and had the
great fortune during the last couple of
years as a faculty member in the late
80s of spending time in Kampala Uganda
as the leader of the adult cancer center
our caring for patients with Kaposi
sarcoma and a lot of my early thinking
about product development actually came
from the time I spent in Uganda caring
for patients with Kaposi sarcoma and a
real quest and a passion to make life
better for patients in the mid 90s I
came to San Francisco again to join
Genentech the first biotech company and
had a lot of wonderful experiences in
product development at Genentech and one
of those great experiences is the story
that I want to tell you about today so
let's talk about some big picture things
about great drug development and when I
say drug development I mean the entire
process of bringing an idea or a concept
from the labs into the clinic and then
to the through the approval process so
that the medicine can be broadly
available for patients first and
foremost and you can't do great drug
development without it you need a very
deep understanding of the basic science
what's the hypothesis you're testing
what's the question you're asking and
does that question make sense given the
basic science and the fundamentals
behind what you're trying to prove the
characteristics of the drug are
important if the drug doesn't get to the
target or it doesn't stay long enough in
the circulation the half-life then you
can't improve the outcome for that
patient targeting the right patients or
personalizing that there
B is the modern way to do drug
development and in part it's the modern
way to do drug development based on
experiences like the one we had with
Herceptin setting a high bar in the
clinic isn't something everyone does the
risk of setting a high bar in the clinic
is that you can fail the benefit of
setting a high bar in the clinic is that
if you succeed it matters a lot it makes
a big difference
people need to rewrite the textbooks
think again about what is possible for
those patients so setting a high bar in
the clinic is the most inspirational way
to do great drug development and what I
actually liked most about great drug
development is you don't do it alone you
have to work effectively with colleagues
in a collaborative way and you
particularly have to work effectively
with key regulatory decision-makers in
America that's the Food and Drug
Administration but there are similar
bodies all over the world and you have
to work effectively with those
regulators so you can do the clinical
trials and ultimately so you can have
broad applicability of your new product
so let me start the Herceptin story with
telling you about the scientific
rationale in breast cancer and this
story really rests on some critical
information about the role of oncogenes
in driving cancer and this specific
antigen human epidermal growth factor
receptor 2 or her2 is a gene that was
thought to be associated with
accelerating the growth of breast cancer
and the first clinical description of
that growth acceleration came from
Dennis layman and his colleagues as
published in science in 1987 and it's
shown on this slide if patients had too
much her to either amplification or over
expression of her - as measured by fish
or immunohistochemistry that was
associated with a shorter survival so
about 25 percent of women in this trial
were her2 positive or overexpressing
and their median survival was only 3
years whereas the her2 normal about 75
percent of when
who had a normal amount of her to lived
a median of six to seven years that's a
dramatic difference and that matters in
the clinic that had a big impact when I
was a practicing oncologist on how I
thought about the outcomes in those
patients so what that meant for a
patient is she could only expect to live
half as long as her fellow breast cancer
patients who were her two normal at the
time this study was done it was
particularly troubling to see this
outcome because we had no remedy for
this her2 positive status and the
patient's so this description was
scientifically compelling but in terms
of drug development it also outlined for
us an unmet need a difficult situation
for patients that potentially we could
fix so here's the molecule that allowed
us to think about addressing this her2
positive or her2 overexpressing
breast cancer and this is the the
picture or a cartoon showing trastuzumab
trastuzumab is the yu-san name or what
some people call the generic name for
her septum I'm going to use Herceptin
because it's less of a mouthful but this
is the monoclonal antibody and
monoclonal antibodies at the time that
Herceptin was developed were thought to
be kind of a pie in the sky dream for a
smart bullet a guided missile targeted
to certain things like her - that were
expressed on cancer cells and the beauty
of Herceptin was that this monoclonal
antibody was humanized most of the
antibody greater than 90% was human less
than 10% in fact in this case about 7%
was murine and that meant that unlike
some of the early antibodies human
beings didn't reject the antibody as
foreign so Herceptin was a humanized
monoclonal antibody that specifically
targeted her to allowing us to test the
hypothesis if we direct an antibody
against her - can we improve outcomes in
women with her2 positive breast cancer
so this is a slide that shows you the
development timeline
herceptin and a couple points I want to
make on this slide you notice the slide
is a very long time line it takes a lot
of time to do great drug development and
that's because each step along the way
you ask an answer specific questions now
the first study of Herceptin was all the
way back in 1991 and that's when the
investigational new drug or IND was
filed to ask FDA we want to do clinical
trials with this new concept for
patients in the clinic by 1994 the phase
two studies were being done based on an
early read that this was safe enough to
give patients in Phase two you ask is
this medicine going to help patients
does it look promising and you start to
figure out the dose for which you're
going to do the most important phase of
testing or phase three which opened up
in 1995 what the other things that are
shown in this slide as we get into the
late 90s and then into the 2000s are a
series of steps with the regulators with
the US regulators in in terms of filing
a BL a or a biologic license application
and with the X US regulators and what
this shows is that something had to be
done that's special with a targeted
therapy and that special thing is filing
both Herceptin or trastuzumab approval
and her subtest this makes drug
development even more challenging you
have to ask for approval of your product
Herceptin and simultaneously asked for
approval for your diagnostic her sub
tests these were both concurrently
approved in 1998 in the metastatic
setting or breast cancer that has spread
and then not until 2005 did FDA approved
Herceptin in the adjuvant setting or
following primary surgery as adjunctive
to standard chemotherapy
now the her2 testing part of the
Herceptin experience was a critical part
of the lessons I learned about product
development when I worked on Herceptin
and what this slide shows you
a great example of why a diagnostic
matters so much
it actually makes drug development
cheaper and faster and why is that well
this is a statistical representation of
what might have been with the Herceptin
study in patients whose breast cancer
has spread metastatic breast cancer our
MBC we knew before Herceptin median
survival was 22 months so 50% of
patients had died by 22 months when you
studied first-line metastatic breast
cancer let's say that we expected the
benefit of Herceptin to be to extend
that survival from 22 months to 27
months or a five month improvement in
survival well if everyone in the study
or a hundred percent of the patients
were her2 positive that five month
difference would take about twelve
hundred and fifty patients and fifty-two
months duration of study if we didn't
have the diagnostic test and truth was
that only 25% of our study population
had her to overexpression that study
would have shown in only a 1.25 month
difference and taken three hundred and
forty nine months and eleven thousand
patients we couldn't have done that
study that study wasn't possible so the
diagnostic allowed for a smaller patient
group and a faster study and here's the
answer to the question does Herceptin
help women with metastatic breast cancer
the great news is the answer is yes in
fact as we had predicted the median
survival extended from twenty point
three months to twenty five point four
months a 25% improvement in survival in
women with metastatic breast cancer all
of whom were her2 positive when treated
with Herceptin even better news came
when we studied Herceptin early on the
adjuvant setting the time to first
distant recurrence doubled the time that
women stayed in remission doubled when
Herceptin was given just after surgery
and this news was so dramatic that it
got a standing ovation when it was
for the first time in my experience the
first time I've ever seen a standing O
at a medical meeting great news for
patients treated with Herceptin here's
the New England Journal article that
talked about that great news for women
in the adjuvant setting her2 positive
treated with Herceptin and the most
important thing that I want to point out
in this du England Journal article is
the last line this will completely alter
our approach to the treatment of breast
cancer now you have to ask is the
patient her2 positive can you help women
by targeting this scientifically based
new therapy at what could become the
Achilles heel of the cancer and the
answer was yes so let me come back to
the key things we understood the science
we had the right drug we targeted the
right patients set a high bar survival
in the clinic and we worked all the way
along the line with the Food and Drug
Administration and the best thing about
working on Herceptin and the experience
I had was I know now hundreds of
thousands of patients are going to
benefit from this work and that's the
best news of all in great drug
development
you